the strongest demon slayer's demon
brother inosuke's demon father an upper
Moon that's secretly a good guy and
every other demon moon in history
including interesting ones from Bonus
materials that 99 of you don't know
about will be discussed in this video so
make sure to stay tuned for that if you
enjoy seeing demon Center content make
sure to smash that like button for more
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications so you don't miss
future demonstrate videos like this one
first let me explain how the 12 demon
moons are organized they are divided
into six lower moons who have their
number in one eye and six upper moons
who have their numbers in both eyes
directly below upper Moon 6 you have
lower Moon one rather than Moon seven
the weakest is lower Moon 6 and the
strongest is upper Moon one we'll start
with the weakest and move to the
strongest so the video will only get
more hype as we move towards the end so
make sure to stay tuned all the way now
I want to shout out to sponsor of
today's video AFK Arena AFK Arena's 4th
anniversary celebration starts soon and
that means High benefits for players
participate in the anniversary event to
get 100 summons it's not my first time
shouting out this awesome game but if
you didn't know if Carolina is a
collectible RPG with a stunning 2D art
style that now has 40 million users
worldwide whether you're a veteran or
have never played before the 100 summons
anniversary special and the hype new
Crossover with the re-zero anime make
this the best time for you to enjoy the
excellent aesthetic experience and idle
fun of AFK you don't gotta spend all
your time grinding just check the game
from time to time your team will be
getting stronger each time and you can
just focus on enjoying the various
gameplay modes like PVE stories dungeons
raid bosses and more I love how you can
create your own Squad of waifus in this
game with cool and unique powers and as
mentioned on the grand celebration of
the fourth anniversary The Crossover
with 3-0 is launched allowing you to add
REM and Amelia to your collection
whether you prefer Rama or Amelia both
are satisfying to watch as Amelia takes
out opponents with her eyes and Ram with
her Morning Star REM will even join the
tavern where you can meet her as a bar
maid and let her walk you through the
basics of this land of Adventures you
can enjoy the brand new thematic dungeon
with REM and Amelia and use their
awesome powers to win the battle and the
treasure so what are you waiting for now
is the time to restart your life in AFK
Arena and re-zero by clicking my link in
the description right now and don't
forget to use promo codes AFK re-zero
unlucky2023 come and meet a million RAM
for yourself in AFK lower Moon 6 used to
be kyogai the drum demon however he
slowly lost the ability to eat humans
muzon was disappointed that he had
already reached his limit and took away
his lower Moon 6 title so he failed as a
demon Moon he tried his hand at writing
but he was told it's boring he was told
that everything he wrote was trash and
that he should stop writing he did not
respond well to the criticism and killed
the harsh critic using his demon powers
so he failed at writing too his whole
life he was told by people he wasn't
good enough only tanjiro as he kills him
Praises him he says that his blood demon
art is very impressive and that actually
makes yogai happy he asks tanjiro if it
is really strong and Tundra says it's
very strong kyogai is touched that
tanjiro saw value in him when everyone
else had always told him that he was
worthless he's touched that Tundra
recognized that his manuscripts don't
deserve to be stepped on kyogai was so
overwhelmed that he began to cry as he
disappeared he was a demon and he killed
people he had to be stopped however his
dying scene shows us that kyogai's life
might have been very different if only
he was surrounded by people who
recognized his value earlier on rather
than people who constantly put him down
and made him feel worthless it took more
than demon blood to turn him into a
monster now let's talk about his
impressive Powers he can manipulate his
drum house by using the drums all over
his body not only can he make the house
rotate Left Right forwards and backwards
he can use the drum on his chest to
create a claw attack and the drum on his
back to teleport himself into another
room he can increase the speed of his
drumming to increase the speed of
rotation and the number of slashes that
appear when he uses his claw attack I
have to admit along with Tundra I was
impressed by the drum Powers when I saw
them in action the newer lower Moon 6
was named kamanui after lower Moon 5 rui
was killed muzon called the lower demons
together including kamanui he is furious
that the lower demons are so weak
kamanui is the first lower moon moves on
kills not because he talks back but
because he thought back muzon can
usually read all of people's thoughts if
he gave them blood and if they are
invisible range so he kills kamanue
before he turns his attention to the
other lower moons unfortunately kamanuet
dies before we get to see his unique
powers lower Moon 5 was rui the cool
looking Spider-Man demon his backstory
is tragic like that in most demons rui
was born with a weak body he never ran
and it was even difficult for him to
walk muzon helped him get a strong Body
by turning him into a demon the only
problem was now he had to eat people and
he had to avoid the Sun at all costs his
parents wanted him to have a strong body
but they were devastated by the fact
that he began killing humans Once Upon a
Time rui was touched by a story he heard
where parents died in order to save
their child who was drowning in a river
he was moved by the parental love and
the bond that caused them to sacrifice
their own lives for another he always
wanted that Bond but his parents tried
to kill him instead so rui killed them
and began searching for real bonds he
created a fake spider family and tried
to force family bonds using fear
obviously that didn't work but he
eventually realizes that the bond he had
with his parents was genuine they
weren't bad people they were going to
take the life of demon rui and then
their own lives the fact that rui killed
innocent people and would continue to
kill innocent people couldn't be
overlooked but his parents were ready to
atone with him by sacrificing their own
lives even as she was dying rui's mother
apologized because she couldn't give him
a healthy body there was a genuine Bond
there but rui thought he had severed it
by killing them however as he's dying he
sees his parents again 10. they welcome
him back with open arms and forgive all
of his actions they're going to follow
rui wherever he goes even if it's the
underworld despite the fact that they
committed no sense themselves this is
one of the most touching moments in the
series and it illustrates the fact that
rui had the strongest of family bonds to
begin with rui apologizes he takes full
responsibility for everything and cries
in the arms of his loving parents as the
Flames of Hell approach the United
Family I give 10 billion points to the
mangaka for being able to make me
sympathize with a character who seemed
so cold and brutal in the beginning and
even hurt our precious nazuko onto the
spider powers rui easily out classes
kyogai and that's reflected in the fact
that Tundra and nezuko unlock new OP
abilities and it's still not enough to
defeat the rui this demon fights with
spider webs that are insanely strong and
sharp when he goes full power the
threads turn red and are even more
powerful despite how epic the dance of
the fire god was and oh man was it epic
rui was intelligent enough to use his
strings to rip off his own head so that
he can simply attach it later however he
was no match for GUI who not only
rendered the op red strings meaningless
with his Dead Calm ability but went on
to cut off the Demon's head in the blink
of an eye before he could even remove it
himself to put the cherry on top of the
cake guyu had a completely stoic
emotionless face when he cut this op
Demon's head off when all the screaming
and emotions in the world couldn't help
tanjara defeat that same demon I must
say the way rui's death is written from
his fight with tanjiro to his family
reunion in the afterlife is masterfully
done lower Moon 4 was called mukago she
was a two-horned demon and she was the
most cowardly out of all of the demon
moons muzon read her mind and figured
out that mukago always intended to plea
if she ever encountered a hashida
obviously muzon is going to punish such
cowardice he quickly kills the sweating
and crying mukago and as with kamanui we
never get to figure out what mukago's
specific Powers were lower Moon 3 was
called wakuraba he had x-shaped scars on
his forehead and cheeks he tries to run
away from muzon before he can kill him
but muzong quickly beheads him as with
some some of the other lower moons we
never get to see wakuraba's Powers lower
Moon 2 was called rokuro he begged
musana to kill him he said he would
definitely be useful to muzon he tells
the demon king of Pop to give him more
of his blood and he'll become stronger
but the fact that a lower Moon would
dare give him instructions only
infuriates muzon and that was the end of
the line for rokuro his powers were also
not revealed but don't worry we get to
see all of the stronger demons use their
op powers and they get very crazy indeed
now before moving on to lower mode 1 we
need to discuss Heidel a former lower
Moon too he debuted in kojo rengoku's
Side Story at this point kyojuro was not
hashira yet and defeating Hyrule was
actually what finally allowed him to be
promoted to the position of lame hashira
kyojiro's father shinjuru faced hairo
before and humiliated him so the demons
swore Revenge he spent years growing
stronger until he became one of the
demon moons he actually thinks kyjo is
shinjuru when he sees him his human
backstory is that he was a swordsman and
a follower of bush though but one day
dudes with guns took him down and
taunted him by saying and I quote try
stopping our bullets with Bushido end
quote he came to think of Bushido as a
relic of the past and that's why he
primarily uses guns as a demon lower
Moon 2 Jairo has the unique and bizarre
trait of shooting himself in the head to
help him keep calm he also uses other
weapons like rifles machine guns and
timed bombs in battle his blood demon
art lets him create and manipulate
shadows in unique ways he can store
stuff like weapons in the shadows and
then pull them out when desired we also
see him use Shadow wolves to attack
mitsuri and they are able to absorb
weapons used against them his final move
blood demon art capture cavity werewolf
of Horror props for how long that name
is lets him become a Giant Shadow Wolf
in this form he wields a sword against
rengoku but kyojuru comes out Victorious
Hydro can't help but say that he admires
on Goku's swordsmanship before he
disappears look at that even demon
enemies loving Goku lower Moon 1 was the
sadistic end move enmu perhaps
unintentionally used reverse psychology
on most on and it worked wonderfully
while the others were begging for their
lives emu was excited by the prospect of
muzon personally killing him rather than
fearing death the sadistic demon was
grateful that muzon saved him for last
and allowed him to listen to the screams
of the other lower moons muzon was won
over by enmu's unorthodox behavior and
instead of Killing Him Muson gave him an
abundance of his blood to make him
stronger his special powers allow him to
enter someone's dreams and he can
destroy their minds by destroying their
spiritual core within the dream however
going into someone's dream can be
dangerous so he sent others in his stead
to locate and Destroy his enemy's
spiritual core additionally his blood
which he mixes into the train tickets
puts people to sleep if they touch it if
all that wasn't enough he can also
assimilate his body with large inanimate
objects like a train in this way he can
potentially eat and assimilate all the
hundreds of trained passengers he can
detach body parts like hands or his head
and they can continue to move and even
talk as well his Talking Hands can even
hypnotize people into falling asleep
this guy is just full of Handy tricks
how however tantro's Dance of the fire
god cuts through his trained spine and
effectively puts an end to enmu's dreams
now before moving on to the hype upper
moons I need to mention one more former
lower Moon one ubume when she was human
she was called yai before she was turned
into a demon by muzon himself she was a
wife and mother who cared deeply for her
loved ones however after becoming a
demon she became Twisted cruel and
merciless she is the primary antagonist
of the third demonstrator light novel
ubume is the demon Moon that sun and me
beat in order to become a hashira
however sanami lost his friend Masa
chica cumeno in that battle showing how
strong ubume was her demon art was being
able to cast powerful illusions that
could even trick the kinoi ranked sonami
at the time and now no offense to the
lower moons but it's time to jump into
the more powerful and more hype upper
moons the title of upper Moon 6 used to
belong to Doki and her brother guitaro
so let's start with their tragic
backstory docki's real name was ume
which was the name of the disease that
killed her mother were born 4 and they
started out at the bottom of the food
chain in the red light district they
were a burden because it cost a lot of
money to feed the siblings and keep them
alive kyotaro was born first and his
mother tried to kill him many times
because he was such a nuisance to her he
had a weak body but he desperately tried
to stay alive and he did everyone
laughed at him because of his ugly voice
and appearance but if the words couldn't
hurt him the Rocks they threw at him
definitely could he was ugly dirty
covered in dirt and dandruff and smelled
bad because of all the fleas in a place
that values Beauty Above All Else he was
viewed like a monster and he had to
resort to eating rats and bugs when he
was hungry forget Drake that's the
actual bottom and gyutaro is the one who
started from it however when ume was
born something changed she was his pride
and joy in contrast to him she was
exceptionally pretty he realized that he
was great at fighting and trained so
that he could use a sickle effectively
he became a collector people feared him
and were disgusted because of his ugly
appearance but he began to take pride in
his ugliness now how it felt great his
beautiful sister blew away his sense of
inferiority he wanted both of them to
work together and create Better Lives
for themselves but this dream was
complicated when ume turned 13 and poked
out a Samurai's eye with her hairpin she
was tied up and burned alive while
guitara was away when he came back his
little sister was burned to a crisp
gutaro screamed at the Injustice as
tears flooded down his eyes then while
he was mourning he was attacked from
behind by the samurai he killed the
samurai who as utero points out lived in
a house that sheltered him from the Wind
and Rain the samurai was spoiled by
comparison he had a nice kimono nice
skin full meals and a beautiful futon
probably and this spoiled guy took the
one thing yutaro had going for him his
sister and then tried to take his life
too he struggled his whole life and
worked ceaselessly so he could create a
better life for his sister and then in
an instant someone who was born with
everything burned her alive like it was
nothing not only did the samurai have no
remorse he tried to kill gyutaro too
after gutaro killed the samurai he he
took his sister and searched for help
but as usual no one would come and help
them he finally collapsed on the snowy
ground then upper Moon 2 came and he
gave them both his blood including the
albat that ume gutaro never regretted
his decision to become a demon because
it meant saving his little sister he
also couldn't forgive others for having
better lives and decided that he'll
snatch them away and collect them in the
end gutero feels bad not for himself but
for ume he believes that she would have
had a better life if he hadn't raised
her he feels like he corrupted her in
purgatory he tells his sister not to
follow him because he wants her to be
free from his corruptive influence
however umay just apologizes for
everything and runs to hug him she says
she won't let go and that they'll be
together forever Kyoto is touched then
together they move forward as the Flames
surround them this is another one of the
most touching moments in the manga you
can feel for these two despite all the
horrible things they have done it's
bittersweet it's sad that they were born
into such a cruel and unfair world but
it's kind of beautiful in the middle of
all that pain and suffering they had
each other now let's talk about their
powers docu's blood demon art is Obi
sash manipulation these OB sashes are
made from her flesh they are strong
enough to block nitrogen blades and are
sharp enough to cut down her opponents
she can use these sashes like an octopus
uses tentacles she's like a stronger and
prettier Doc Ock she can turn her own
body parts into these sashes as well for
instance if someone tries to cut off her
neck she can turn it into this Fabric
and it will bend with the sword making
it harder to cut she can also store
living people inside her sashes which
she does to keep her food fresh she can
even detach part of herself and that
sash can act on its own and watch over
things like her stores of living human
victims then there's eutharo's Powers
utero already had skills using a sickle
and his demon powers allow him to
capitalize on those skills he can use
his flesh and blood to create sickles
that are coated with fatal poison he can
send countless blood blades flying at
his opponents he can also take control
of his sister's body and create
perfectly coordinated tag team attacks
another added benefit is that that both
his head and his sister's head have to
be cut off at the same time or they will
simply regenerate in the end Doki and
gutaro were defeated but it took a
hashira a number of talented demon
Slayers a protagonist's op demon sister
some wives and probably some good
old-fashioned luck to just barely win
this was one of my favorite arcs if not
my favorite in the series in a large
part of the reason is because dakian
yutaro made for such amazing and
Powerful antagonists the title of upper
Moon 6 went on to get inherited by
kaigaku who was previously a Demon
Slayer and zenitsu Senpai kaigaku and
zanitsu studied under the same
thunderstyle Sensei because his one
student became a demon they to Sensei
committed sepoku and no one was even
there to cut off his head so he suffered
a long and agonizing death kagaku was
glad that asensei died painfully because
he worked so hard and he was never given
the thunderstyle successor title the
Sensei wanted kagaku who could use every
thunder-style breath except the first to
share the successorship with zenitu who
could only use the first one however
this wasn't enough for the greedy
kaigaku the demon blood made kagaku's
Thunder style even stronger but he still
lost to zanitsu who created his own
seventh form called flaming Thunder God
yoshira later points out that kaigaku
still had no idea how to use his
Newfound demon techniques and abilities
so zenitsu was lucky because he would
have lost if kaigaku had more time to
get used to his demon powers his demon
reinforced Thunder style allows kaigaku
to actually summon his own lightning
which burns flesh and allows him to
strike from a distance the lightning
also acts like a kind of poison
continuing to attack the flesh yushiro
has to apply a special agent that stops
the advance of a blood demon art so that
the slashes on zainsu's face won't
spread all the way to his eyes upper
Moon 5 was Yoko the genie with two
mouths where his eyes should be and an
eye where his mouth should be he creates
gruesome works of art out of the bodies
of his human victims muichiro the Mist
hashira is the one who faces off against
him muichiro awakens a Demon Slayer mark
on his face and with his increased hours
manages to defeat gyoko by cutting off
his head with a quick slash one of those
quick slashes that takes a second to
show the damage now let's talk about
upper Moon 5's power he has multiple
pots and he can teleport between them
until the pots are destroyed he has
another form he can enter when he needs
more power in this form he is covered in
scales that are harder than diamond and
everything his fist touches turns into
sweet little fish to use his own words
he calls himself an existence that knows
no bounds in this form which is why it's
even funnier when a 14 year old ends his
whole career lastly can summon octopus
tentacles from his jar he can trap
enemies in suspended water and he can
release fish-like demons that feed on
enemy flesh and even if the opponent
Cuts them they'll release a poisonous
liquid that can be absorbed through the
skin upper Moon 4 was Han Tengu we get a
glimpse of his past as a human he was a
mentally unstable person who stole and
killed people and then blamed it on his
uncontrollable hands thus he always felt
like a victim and he viewed people who
were trying to bring him to justice as
bullies tanjiro is the one who manages
to finish him off this demon has
impressive stealth skills he can sneak
into the blacksmith village and he can
even sneak up on both muichiro and
tanjiro too skilled and experienced
demon Slayers especially muichiro his
small body also makes him hard to spot
and hit he can divide his emotions and
they'll manifest in different forms that
will fight for him he makes an anger
clone that fights with lightning a joy
clone that fights with wind a sorrow
clone that fights with a spear a
pleasure clone that fights with sound a
fear clone with high defensive abilities
that contain some tengu's core and a
large resentment clone a last line of
defense that hides the original demon in
its heart the anger clone can also
absorb other emotion clones to create
the more powerful hatred clone that
appears to be able to use all the powers
in one since it could use the pleasure
clone Sonic scream it can also summon
powerful wooden dragon heads and as we
know multiple dragon heads are always
powerful AF just look at bloy's Ultimate
Dragon and five-headed dragon from
Yu-Gi-Oh the title of upper Moon 4 got
passed down to nakime the emotionless
Cyclops musician as Mitra points out
nakime can move her interdimensional
Fortress as if it were her own hands and
feet we're told her powers aren't very
deadly but they make her very difficult
to defeat she's like an advanced version
of former lower Moon 6 demon kyogai
while kyogai controls his house document
controls what seems to be an infinite
interdimensional Fortress she can bring
anyone she desires into the Fortress and
she is able to create teleporting doors
wherever she wants this way she can
teleport her opponent somewhere else if
they try to attack her she can also
create several detached eyeballs from
her body and use them to spy on people
from long range this ability allowed her
to locate many demon Slayers across
Japan it even allowed her to locate the
well-hidden Mansion of kagaya ubuyashiki
which was supposed to be one of the best
kept secrets in the entire series upper
Moon 3 was akaza who actually had one of
my favorite backstories and character
arcs in the series I definitely didn't
think I'd feel this way after he killed
the flame hashira Kyo Jordan Goku but
the mangaka pulled off some top tier
writing Witchcraft and made me some
empathize with hakaza even though I
didn't want to keep in mind he was 18
when he became a demon so he was still
practically a kid but let's take a look
at his life up to becoming a demon he
was born with fangs so he was called a
demon child all his life when he was
growing up akasa had a sick father who
needed expensive medicine so from a
young age akasa was forced to steal so
he could afford the medicine the tattoos
on his demon body seemed to be inspired
by actual tattoos he was given as a kid
for pickpocketing he was visibly marked
as a criminal for all to see at a very
young age he felt like he had to become
stronger so he could run away with more
wallets beat up people came for revenge
and escaped the magistrate after
receiving three pickpocketing tattoos he
was told that his wrists would be cut
off next time but an 11 year old akaza
after receiving 100 blows told them to
go ahead and cut his wrists off since
he'd still have his feet to use for
pickpocketing then one day he got some
really heartbreaking news his father had
hung himself because he wanted akasa to
live an honest life and he didn't want
to live off money that was stolen from
others in a letter he apologized for
being a nuisance to his son however
akasa never viewed his father as a
nuisance his father never did anything
wrong in fact his father was his reason
for living he would have gladly endured
the harshest punishment for his dad even
if they lasted a hundred years after his
father took his own life akaza hugged
his grave and cursed the unjust world he
got into brawls with people and in one
instance he beat up seven adults with
his bare fists that's when keizo the
bear fisted martial arts master entered
his life and whooped his butt for his
own good he took akasa into his home
despite the fact that he was banished
from Edo for being a criminal not only
that he trusted him to take care of his
sick daughter while he was at work his
wife used to do it but she drowned
herself from the fatigue of nursing her
she feared that her daughter would only
get worse and worse until she died and
she couldn't just wait for that to
happen anymore akasa started caring for
koyuki his sensei's daughter and he fell
in love with her he had hit rock bottom
when his dad died but he finally found a
new reason to live and things eventually
got better than they'd ever been akaza
was such a good guy that he hated when
people apologized for being sick he knew
that they would help themselves if they
could and more importantly he wanted to
help them he never saw helping others as
a bother rather he saw it as the least
he could do and what's more it gave his
life purpose at one point feels bad that
akasa is missing out because of her and
asks him to go watch fireworks however
he prefers to stay by her side and tells
her that they'll go next year or the
year after that he wants to go see them
with her when she's feeling better koiki
was so touched by that that she cried
akasa found out that this Sensei got the
dojo when he saved the previous owner
however arrival Dojo was jealous and
made sure he had no students akaza was
saved by a Sensei and his daughter
training in the dojo and nursing koyuki
healed his heart he was there for over
three years and koyuki was starting to
live normally akaza Sensei offered akaza
his dojo and his daughter's hand in
marriage because he had the tattoos of a
criminal he never imagined having a
future at all let alone of future where
he was loved by someone and yet here he
was being told that it was going to
happen he would get more than he could
ever have hoped for but just when he got
everything he could have ever wished for
it all got slashed away when he was away
his Sensei and his fiancee were poisoned
they were poisoned because the
aforementioned jealous martial artists
couldn't beat Sensei Kaizo or akaza in a
fair fight so they resorted to poisoning
their well there's also the fact that
the heir of the dojo next door was in
love with koyuki so he was infuriated
that akaza then called hakuji was going
to marry her once again akasa couldn't
save those who were most precious to him
he had promised to protect his fiancee
for his entire life and he felt like he
broke that promise akasa went on to
attack the Rival Dojo that was
responsible for the poisoning he killed
67 Swordsmen with his bare hands as time
passed no one could believe that such a
thing actually happened and the recorded
events of that night were regarded as a
fictitious tale for 30 years before
being erased muzon showed up when akasa
no longer wanted to live akasa was
turned into a demon and lost his
memories he kept wanting strength even
though he no longer had a thing to
protect and yet as a demon he never
killed women and eventually he regains
his emotions and as koyuki puts it
returns to his original Self although as
a demon he could have kept fighting
tanjiro he decided to stop and go to the
afterlife gracefully tragically he
couldn't join the ones he loved in
heaven because of his actions but he
died happy because they never stopped
loving him now after hearing that try
and tell me that this isn't a
beautifully written character you can't
do it now let's turn to his powers he is
insanely strong he beat rengoku and
would have probably defeated Dance of
the fire god tanjiro and awaken Mark
giyu if he didn't choose to die a
graceful death instead so we're talking
insane power in his demon form akaza's
already impressive strength and fighting
skills dramatically increase not to
mention his regenerative power his Blood
Demon technique allows him to create
shockwave-like attacks it also allows
him to detect bloodlust or fighting
spirit in his enemies his final
technique is called blue silver chaotic
Afterglow he launches countless shock
waves at an incredible speed even though
gyu tried to neutralize it with deadcom
he failed and was hit with a hundred
blows almost all at once and here's a
bonus fact for the hardcore fans notice
how snowflake patterns appear below
akaza as he uses his technique well it's
not random koyuki's name contains the
meaning for snow and she used to wear
snowflake hair decorations how romantic
is that even after losing his memories
and becoming a demon his love for koyuki
still manifested itself upper Moon 2 was
Doma The Eccentric cult leader demon he
was born with rainbow colored eyes and
was groomed to be the religious leader
of the Eternal Paradise cult his father
kept making love to his female cult
followers and as a result dolma's mother
stabbed him to death she went crazy and
took her own life with poison Doma
wasn't concerned about his parents being
dead though he was concerned about the
mess his mother made in the room Not For
a Moment did he feel sad or lonely human
emotions were nothing to to him even
before he turned into a demon and it was
at age 20 that moves on finally turned
him into one Domo was pretty busy as a
demon cult leader he wasn't sleeping
with its cult followers as far as we
know but he was eating them at some
point he turned gyutaro andaki into
demons he also crossed paths with
inosuke inosuke's Mother escaped to the
Eternal Paradise called to get her and
her baby son away from an abusive
household so you could say that dolma
became a kind of demon stepfather to him
at this point Doma actually intended to
let inosuke's mother live out her
lifespan he wasn't going to eat her she
was beautiful and had a great singing
voice however she found out that Doma
was eating other followers she fled and
dropped baby nosuke off a cliff before
Doma caught up and killed her he assumed
the baby was as good as dead but as we
know inosuke is a tough dude and managed
to survive Jungle Book style then there
was the time he killed Kane kocho the
flower hashira this marked the end of
him in a way kanae's younger sister
shinobukochro the insect hashira set out
to get revenge and she does in the most
epic fashion she fills her body with
custom poison over a long period of time
and allows dolma to eat her this poison
weakens him enough so that the adoptive
younger sister of Kanai and shinobu can
finish him off with some help from
inosuke this is one of the best revenge
arcs I've seen in anime and it makes
this fight one of my favorites doma's
demon powers allow him to create ice and
frost by using his own flesh and blood
he uses two fans to help Channel his ice
powers he can create ice clones of
himself to fight for him for his
strongest attack he can create a giant
bodhisattva statue out of ice that
statue can attack enemies and it
produces deadly cold air that can freeze
opponents however he waited too long to
use this attack and since he was so
weakened by the poison Doma and his
overpowered Giant Eye statue were
defeated the strongest and final upper
Moon upper Moon 1 was kokushibu the
sixth-eyed samurai the strongest demon
Moon used to be a Demon Slayer named
michikatsu tsugikuni he was also the
brother of yorichi tsugikuni the
strongest demons there in history who
beat moves on in the past and gave him
PTSD before becoming a demon he had a
child that would keep his bloodline
going for centuries in fact the
hashiramui chirotokito is a descendant
of his michikatsu received the Demon's
hair Mark that drastically increases
one's power at some point but as he
explains The Marked Ones die before they
reached the age of 25. those who show
The Mark after 25 will quickly die
turning into a demon was a way for
kokoshibo to avoid death while
increasing his power even more he was
also always jealous of his brother
yerichi and wanted to become the
strongest he thought that becoming a
demon would help him to do it but he
sacrificed everything for nothing since
an old eurichi was still significantly
stronger aside from that time old man
yorichi almost ended him kokushibu went
on to serve as the unbeatable number one
demon moon for centuries upper Moon Juan
kokushibu uses demon-enhanced Moon
breathing since we know that yorichi's
sun breathing is the strongest breath
style it makes sense that his brother's
Moon breathing would be the second
strongest right off the bat however as
with Kagan Aku it becomes even deadlier
when you add Blood Demon Arts to it
every slash kokoshibo makes with his
sword is surrounded by many Crescent
moon-like blades that change in size and
length this adds power range and
unpredictability to his already
dangerous attacks his sword is made out
of his own flesh and has multiple eyes
on it which increases his range of
vision because it's made of his own
flesh it can regenerate when broken or
even change form and become longer we
see they can summon these blades all
over his body and launch Crescent blades
in all directions when he wishes to and
these blades easily cut through enemy
flesh kokushibu even regenerates his
head after it's cut off like muzon can
do however after he sees the monster
he's become reflected inside of his
sword he begins to disintegrate again
I'm not taking away from all of the
damage that the demon series inflicted
upon him but I think okushibu's pass
finally caught up with him too and that
was a contributing factor to him not
evolving into a demon like muzon that's
immune to beheading he wanted to be the
strongest Samurai but then he realized
he was the furthest thing from an
honorable samurai he even contemplated
the ugliness of not admitting defeat
even though they took off his head he
started to realize that this is not what
he wanted and as we saw with akaza the
human psyche prevented demon
regeneration but that was just the tip
of the iceberg and if you want to see
how deep the Demon's air Iceberg
actually goes and discover all the
darkest secrets that dwell deep below
the surface then you don't want to miss
my Demon Slayer Iceberg video link on
screen right now and in the description
see you there